that's right as I'm on vacation I'm out
of town I don't have the ability to
review the movies that are coming out
this weekend I might as well talk about
that trailer that people wanted me to
talk about last month so now I guess
I'll talk about it when I'm out of town
and I got to put up a video for the sake
of keeping the YouTube algorithm going
so it doesn't forget me playing the game
here as someone who really enjoyed the
first Godzilla movie I think this looks
really cool the premise is cliche is out
let's get that out of the way right now
let's be honest about it human beings
are a disease a blight on this planet
and the planet has found a cure that's
pretty much the premise of The Day After
Tomorrow
and it was old and cliche then going
back a few more years is pretty much the
exact dialogue the monologue rather that
Agent Smith has in the matrix however it
always makes for an interesting thing to
happen doesn't always happen in an
interesting movie but that premise is
interesting if you see the earth as an
organism and all of us living on it
we're essentially a little parasites
just the Earth's chronology is much
slower than ours if we saw the earth
moving as an organism each of the
continents move around if you just sped
up time you'd be like all other things
alive so it's just a fascinating premise
to me however the trailer goes on it's
like we need to find these Titans
because if we don't we're gonna get
wiped out I didn't ask are the Titans
not what the Earth's gonna use to wipe
us out what's gonna use to wipe us out
does it have other monsters I lack the
motivation to Google what the [ __ ] that
could be so I wouldn't know but I feel
like a lot of you would is Godzilla the
answer but Godzilla was a good guy in
the first one so I don't think he is the
title of being Godzilla king of the
monsters I feel like either Godzilla's
going to lead the monsters to fight
whatever it is or Godzilla's gonna fight
Rodan Mothra and try Clyde from Mario to
let's just take a step back and just
appreciate the visuals for a second is
holy crap with that I've never so
completely welcomed a giant moth to kill
us all if we all get that view before it
happened the Earth's like I have a
monster oh man we have an 11 and it'll
make your monster army piss their pants
that's what she does the premise of this
movie is mankind is a disease and now
the earth has conjured a fever to fight
off the disease enter the fever which
case I'm like why am i rooting for the
body to not cure itself shouldn't I be
rooting for the body to cure itself to
go against that is essentially being
like yeah I want aids to win right and
it's all very confusing I'm very
conflicted on all this if I'm learning
anything from the first Godzilla movie
we saw 10 minutes of Godzilla and five
minutes of Bryan Cranston so I'm
expecting to see ten minutes of Godzilla
and five minutes of Milly Bobby Brown
whatever the marketing shows you just
bump back your expectations but the
movie looks cool as hell or so Godzilla
king
monsters have you seen the trailer what
did you think about it yeah this is a
trailer from comic-con but actually I've
scheduled this one to go up before I
left so there is a new trailer to
apologize living in the past year
whatever you think of the trailer
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]